à 48 heures de la fête du travail la
maison des communistes si tu attrapes
avenue carlo accélère pour boucler ses
livraisons de muguet la structure doit
répartir plus de 3400 brun dans
l'ensemble du département
c'est un travail important en a - faut
déjà contacté des producteurs surtout en
période de pénurie de muguet comme on a
cette année avec le climat c'est pas si
facile que ça ensuite on regarde les
produits comprend les transmet à nos
sections qui nous passent les commandes
et nous on passe une commande globale
la fête du 1er mai permet au parti
communiste français de récolter près de
600000 euros dans l'hexagone
mais pour la structure ses dettes est
avant tout politique après la vente du
muguet le matin dans les yvelines la
journée se poursuivra par une
manifestation dans les rues de paris
l'après-midi à la vente du muguet c'est
un côté symbolique mais c'est aussi un
petit peu une excuse c'est un moment où
sur l'ensemble du territoire du
département on aura des communistes
partout qu'ils vont vendre le muguet ce
qui est comme une initiative financière
qui est pas négligeable pour pour les
finances de notre fédération mais c'est
aussi un moment des changes politique de
dialogue de discussion c'est la fête des
travailleurs là où le premier
revendications des huit heures par jour
de travail a eu lieu
c'est un grand rassemblement de tous les
travailleurs à une solidarité
internationale également cette année
dans les rues de paris le parti
communiste français le front de gauche
présenteront leur questionnaire baptisé
que demande le peuple
le document a pour but d'analyser les
principaux sujets d'inquiétude des
français